hello everybody welcome back to let's
play dead space - okay we left off with
a train ride from hell
without some monsters I've honed
everyone around me now I have not very
much ammo but that's cool because that
makes you gain a challenge
what's that who wants some ha ha ha
baby Oh kid hi Oh got you Ringo face ha
ha aw what's that not your mom oh gosh
oh who needs that tired of it I heard
event explode soon that was when the
monster was gonna pop out okay that was
like a little little kid I guess this
baby Necromorphs is pretty
understandable if they're not baby ones
as well yo okay
I got uh I got to definitely use these
use telekinesis more often
when I when I have no ammo it's really
gonna save mom behind in the future I
know it's out there anybody
Trixie's fine candies I love me some
candy
ionization elementary I guess I would
make sense it would have an elementary
school oh oh that's where the little
kids are coming from lemon gun
anything behind their esna I think I saw
stores all that ah good he'll go yeah
I'll take that call that phone you hard
i'ma knock it off put that wall up it
won't oh you're the tray it's a stringy
it's got you got you done
give me that take one of your friends
whomp ah no no I don't have anything
else to fry God is unlimited amount of
you the hell good good
take your friend Oh your friends body
killed you
ha ha ha damn it was like a million of
them hello stay old drop stuff hey there
were a lot more bodies I think attract
inner cities ok are the memories come in
it they never left me crazy
uh-huh the bad ones
yeah the monster hit her
Thank You Isaac see the simples - in the
heap seems faced lose face
well go kill some I assume you're a
competent engineer like me and are very
trained in murdering zombie children
anyway there are a lot more bodies in
this and if they're all i'll give me
goodies maybe that's to control them not
giving me so many goodies in my stomach
what the hell light speed
I like these little doodads and in
advertising they have in this game it
makes the game seem more like a real
place and that's important in them
establishing something oh they came out
of fashion kid Osbert it's more
important to establish that we're in a
horror setting there's a certain amount
of unbelievable 'ti to a game if it's
like fantasy or something like that
if you ground it in real aspects she
becomes more relatable to the player and
becomes all that much scarier alright
anyway ah yeah I got the pulse rifle
schematic but I won't do that
alright what if I got force energy I
don't have the foreskin so I can sell
that I'm never gonna get the foreskin
again
I think I need to buy some ammo I don't
have a lot of space um
Oh someone mentioned I should buy the
refurbished plasma cutter but
accidentally already put paranoids in my
one I don't know how much better it is
because it doesn't say like it's got any
damage bonus or anything but I don't
know I don't know either way I need a mo
um let's just go simple I'll stick with
the plasma cutter for now because that's
my basic and I can't go wrong with it
every every other type of ammo I'll pick
up on the way but for now let's get with
the plasma cutter
that's not bad seems to be just as
harmful as it was before maybe I don't
know objective or let me an elevator
ride he's always end well and cold in a
corner
anyone want to jump out at me no sure
kya he was a patient in the project just
like you yeah why was you there what
does he want he's a psychopath Isaak
stay clear of him right he's our wife
and child
okay okay all the careful yeah I believe
you
Jerry did okay Tech's log guild history
series concrete moon part two to a large
colony was established on Titan to study
the moon's every seismic detail and
prepared and prepared for disassembly as
the operation got underway the orbital
platform citizen with the work became
prototypes for the planet crackers that
would soon follow
Titan was successfully cracked and
harvested only slightly behind schedule
it was a major boost for the then
beleaguered population on earth believed
their extinction from lack of resources
was in imminent whoo that's been Titans
harvest was halted before the entire
moon was disassembled leaving only was
dissemble leaving the small shard where
the original colony had started from
here the station grew in leaps and
bounds as the new era planet cracking
got underway serving as both a critical
research outpost and with the advent of
shock point drives away station for all
planet cracking missions going forward
it is now whimsically known as the
sprawl for having done just that over
the many years of its operation okay a
little bit of history I like I like
having a game with a nice backstory I
don't like games they just drop you in
there with as creepy with the ghost
no nothing nothing to have but I do like
that story even stuff like this little
fluff stores like this that are selling
a futuristic bed I'm fixing where you
hover Oh gotcha
I mean that's really cool maybe I'm just
a nerd well I mean I've already admitted
that I'm a big giant nerd holy crap this
is director Tyson's huge man who still
just as ugly as ever
Oh God nice city is what I wanted
nothing is up and down there where my
York find your piece ask us oh this
looks like a marker another text log
okay ho-hum altman's footsteps we the
child children of the marker grow tired
of the oppressive thinly veiled attacks
from EarthGov on our rice to worship as
we please reduced hours of operation for
the church fire marshal restrictions on
the size of revival events permits
needed to distribute literature these
are all poorly concealed attempts to
squat to quash the truth our truth and
they will not succeed the blasphemous
short-sighted reckless destructive and
hopeless path that the EarthGov has us
on is a dead end one that only has us
one that only unit ology has the answer
to Altman has foreseen it we are the
Blessed to execute it prepare yourselves
brothers and sisters convergence is nigh
okay some crazy church okay I remember a
lot of Unitologist talking about in the
other game all epically hacking skills
haha what's that another one no don't
touch it the best engineer ever just
ripping wires out of a wall
um we like their prayer whoa I thought
you were rounding me to residential
this looks like a unit ology recruitment
center am I still on track yes
there's an old maintenance access point
in there that'll take you through the
waste disposal system and into the
Cassini towers file stay sharp
Cheney towers that's all familiar from
NASA wasn't there a Cassini towers and
Mass Effect another tax Locker um good
to hear a lot of my voice let's see meh
fully paid recruiting has slowed
markedly in the last few weeks is surely
due to earth cuffs recent slander
campaign painting us as carpetbaggers
and insurrectionists in the press
regents from the churches at venice way
board and in and the heliopause observer
are shocking in later this week to
strategize a response or are shocking in
as in traveling and expect additional
budget to be allocated to public
relations and media to combat this trend
also the CAC
layoffs continue to negatively affect
recruiting and targets we're down almost
30 percent year on you get all out it's
French
okay again i love-love-love backswing
oh no ha ha got ya Hans a bad idea how's
the big triangle all their items ah ah
what the hell
take your friend take a sign in the face
how about that
I'm not dicker Wow yeah yeah not that I
need that walk walk
yeah okay
getting good at killing this that was
iam too dangerous when they lunge at you
they kind of just flounder in the air a
little bit
maybe unitards is followed you not
really one mind one soul uh-huh
there seems to be a lot worse than war
going on here
for the edges oh no I don't like these
things why are they here
why do I have to go through
don't like don't like them nothing has
happened yet oh no in the beginning in
the first one I saw a monster I saw one
in oh don't touch it
he's clean thank you nope
Wow
okay oh hello buddy better okay well
this is this listen up I'm listening you
can use Kinesis typical blades off dead
ones
and shoot back again ah yeah I watch you
watch
new here extry I was using this chick
you see shoot it back you're gonna bleed
out soon
make it pretty bad in there so hope this
helps you
y'all ready knew that but thanks anyway
dead guy why didn't you get some armor
Yorgi garbage okay it's locked
fantastic I should know I should just
follow my mother followed a marker
follow two marker what I can't go here
y'all everyone I'm stupid what the hell
oh look at it save real quick here
dudu and Benjy bench why many partners I
don't know how many I picked up on the
way here for two empty spaces
that's the target on fire when shot cool
oh the one I'm going to definitely keep
here to this detonator I love this dead
let's have purple specialty increase the
splash damage radius of the month okay
so bigger explosion um wow that's a love
it I'm gonna need a lot of time I'm
gonna be upgrading alright that should
be for Joe and I pick out two guns I
like I'm going to filter out an
aggressive gun and I'll
okay actually I'm gonna hold off on
pressing this button here look at that
pretty look at that all right finally
that's all the time I got for this part
thank you guys so much for watching and
as always see you in the next bye bye